It was hard mentally to play that game.
But we have played so long and we have done so many comebacks we always believe in ourselves.
Thorin: What's crazy about the success of the new Fnatic lineup
It feels like it's really made us actually kind of take greatness for granted
Because already, this is clearly one of the best CS:GO teams we've ever seen.
Richard Lewis: Fnatic undergone a very large roster change
Thorin: Yeah the problem this team has is the identity of the team has gone completely.
KRIMZ: Once the whole team just started to tilt and just having small arguments
Everyone just started to hate, small hate, each other and
It broke down the team
Once upon a time, Fnatic were the best team in CS:GO
Recently,  Fnatic fans were treated to a return to glory as core crew
KRIMZ, JW and Flusha showed us they still got what it takes
with newcomers Golden and Lekr0 of course.
Proving that they don't need no olofmeister, here's the best of Fnatic at IEM Katowice.
[Casting]